when it comes to fashion and street
style it's hard to find a place more
diverse a creative and unique than
London so we traveled all over the city
in search of people making waves and
leaving their own unique mark in the
fashion world
[Music]
first up is a dynamic duo in South
London in their colourful salon we own a
Technicolor hair sculpture salon in
southeast London depth first we have
created a non judgment Bey salon who
caters to all hair types and gender
identities this is a space for everybody
and it's a comfortable safe space where
everyone can come in and hit their
dreams dream come true I'd say
personally my style is just like her
painters canvas I like to look like a
working piece of art my faul is cosmic
clown I come from another galaxy
London's a massive inspiration because
we're surrounded by creative people that
express themselves on a daily basis that
aren't afraid that are fearless we felt
from transforming ourselves we want to
share you know want people to feel the
same way that's the whole point of our
shop is to inspire the world next up we
went to South London to meet a designer
who was redefining the runway with her
sustainable designs I'm a fashion and
textiles designer illustrator and artist
if you imagine taking a bunch of
different ingredients and you put it in
one big cooking pot that's kind of
London style I'm all about having
meaningful conversations through
clothing and promoting sustainability
through fashion factories tend to
manufacture rolls of denim and some of
them have defects so they can't be sold
and they can't be used so I tend to
source from that and then deconstruct
everything and reconstruct it to make
something new one of the reasons I tend
to cast all black models isn't so much
just about making a statement but it's
because I think it's important that
people become normalized to seeing those
things I'm really passionate about
trying to create a brand which extends
beyond making clothes and putting it in
stalls it's informing and educating
people of different cultures different
techniques
[Music]
tottenham is a melting pot of different
cultures traditions and food it comes as
no surprise that we met our next
designer here I'm a menswear brand based
in London my designs are influenced by
both my Scottish and my Jamaican
heritage this hats a good example of
Scottish fabric or yarn and then I was
looking a lot of like the big dread
Tom's in Jamaica the raw material
Scottish and the influence is looking at
what would be made in Jamaica and using
it together the reason why I like to
introduce unorthodox colors and patterns
and prints is a way of bringing new
light traditional fabrications we've got
such a long history of knitwear made in
Scotland so for me it's like going into
these manufacturers who have all this
history and how I can bring it forward
for the contemporary man of today I have
this balance between past and present
and craftsmanship when you fuse it
together then make something quite
powerful then we travel to Savile Row
where one woman is shaking things up and
making history I'm the owner of corny
and gambled in Savile Row Savile Row is
the global epicenter for menswear
bespoke suits that I'm the first women's
wear only tailors in the history of the
streets I think my identity really
benefits the business in is that it is
young is very feminine like this
double-breasted suit is traditionally a
very male outfit but doing it and like
baby pink and with a pair of like epic
boot cuts it gives it a kind of I don't
care quality because all of my customers
are women it has made some of the
menswear tailor's be more open to having
female customers for example some of the
shops women weren't even allowed into
the shop they had to wait outside until
their husbands were done so I think now
people are starting to think ok maybe
she was on to something full of the
makers that I work with I make sure
everyone has really Fair Pay everyone
has four weeks holiday year the learning
am i empowering the women that i dress
but I'm empowering the women I employ
imagine little Wayne wearing one of your
designs for our next creative that dream
became a reality I'm an artist goldsmith
working with precious metals everything
I make is made with my own two hands I
don't even use a computer assisted
design so everything is hand carved at
the end of the last year I got this
random email for someone who wanted a
piece of work and at first I turned them
away and then I found out the piece was
for a little way and then I said yeah
absolutely of course another do it it
was a dream for me because I'm a massive
little way friend I'm very connected to
my work in particular working with gold
and silver and metals
it's miniature sculpture for me they're
just miniature artworks that live in a
social realm jewelry is a huge part of
me and and how I style myself by wearing
these pieces they also start discussions
it's almost like being a little
billboard the things that you wear or
you carry with your body are very
important otherwise you wouldn't hold
them close to your skin my name is joy
b/c my name is Phoebe gourmet recluse de
tolly coca Pony tips tutti frutti
and these are my foods
[Music]
you